in the last week Azerbaijan troops
attack Armenia Armenia as a prime
minister pashino so attack Armenia Kappa
Hunter soldiers die there's a lady named
anush which you see the story
circulating all over the place who the
azerbaijani military apparently took her
they you know raped her they got they
took a rise out they put rocks there
they took out her fingers put on her
mouth and this story is going all over
the place and another Soldier Armenian
Soldier this has been happening
constantly now when somebody says
stories like this you know what a lot of
friends from Azerbaijan will say how
could you say that you're selling us
that evil people and no problem fine
let's speculate together as a person
who's Armenian who you know what side
I'm going to lean on and I quite frankly
don't even think that pashinian is the
right leader in the country right now
because while you're doing this
everything's about alliances you create
look at Israel Israel created alliances
with America you went and were bought
out by China and then Russia is
supporting you in a way but they kind of
run Armenia you're not really the
president of our the Prime Minister of
Armenia is really Russia but Russia is
also playing politics for a couple
different reasons so Watch What Happens
turkey yeah this is the part where a
person like Putin has a good argue not
necessarily Putin some people who are
from the side that they're saying NATO's
playing games
this is what a Turkish Member of
Parliament just said a couple days ago I
want you to play it and then I'm going
to read what it translates to he just
said this on September 15th okay play it
put the audio up and then I'll say
exactly what he's saying to you go and
press play
so here's a message I don't know if you
get in the audio or not start over Tyler
okay if you're getting it don't worry
about it you can go watch us on Twitter
here's what he says we say to the
Armenian Administration make up your
mind I remind you once again that the
Turkish nation has the power to erase
Armenia from history geography and that
they stand at the limit of our patients
this is a member of parliament from
Turkey
turkey is part of NATO
if a message like this is being given
this is like somebody from Germany
saying hey uh Israel if you guys make a
comment don't let us remind you of what
we did to you guys back in the days with
this and guess what this guy can you go
up to his Twitter account please go
straight to his Twitter account you have
his handle he's active on Twitter that's
him so he just said this three days ago
this guy's still active on Twitter FYI I
am not imposing for a guy like this to
be banned I want people like this on
Twitter do you know why because people
can get to see that these types of
people exist and you can make a decision
for yourself so now I want to give a
shout out to somebody
Nancy Pelosi I rarely will give a shout
out to Nancy Pelosi but today's one of
them Nancy Pelosi to me is 10 times more
presidential than Joe Biden or Kamala
Harris's now forget about politics
forget how you feel about any of these
three characters here let me just tell
you what I mean by this Nancy Pelosi
went to Taiwan and China said if you do
show look what we're going to do to you
she still went Nancy Pelosi in the
middle of all this
challenges faced between Armenia and
Azerbaijan she goes to Armenia and
spends a day there with a couple of the
political leaders that went with her
Armenian folks that went with her and
she goes pays a respect for what's going
on now here's the part yesterday I go on
Fox News YouTube channel I go on MSNBC
YouTube channel I go and see their
YouTube channel I type in CNN Armenia
you know what you see this much
I go type Fox Armenia this much Pelosi
goes to Armenia nothing's talked about
right so turkey has got azerbaijan's
back okay turkey is a part of NATO and
they made this threat and what does
erdogan say going around saying we're
going to do whatever we're going to do
to Armenia we can make you guys erase
and this you know Parliament member can
say what he can say and they stay on so
moral the story is the following you
gotta bite and a Kamala Harris was just
asked as the Border safe did you see a
response yeah where they ask the
question so is the Border safe and I
don't know if you got the video if you
can pull it out because the video was
just absolutely ludicrous on what she's
saying like you can't even sit there and
process it and say did she really just
say that Tyler I don't know if you got
it up or not you look like you're going
through all of them yeah okay watch this
answer here very weird
the border is secure but we also no go
back because if you didn't go back in
particular over the last four years back
refresh because it needs to be fixed he
asked a question
okay just question first and then it
goes
okay secure but we also have a broken
immigration system in particular over
the last four years before we came in
and it needs to be fixed we're gonna
have two million people across this
border for the first time ever you're
confident this border is secure listen
to her answer
we have
a secure border in that that is a
priority for Any Nation including ours
and our Administration oh you know when
I hear give that answer all she's
thinking about is how is this going to
be written about in the paper how is
this going to be cut so what can I do to
give the right answer or I'm not going
to be judged for it FYI listen people
say Nancy plays politics Everybody Plays
politics guess what you play politics I
want the person playing politics to go
to Armenia I want the person playing
politics to go to Taiwan I want this
person playing politics to go to the
border so you don't want to go to the
Border guess what they brought the
border to you did you see all these
people coming off the bus in front of
our house what'd you think about that
when you saw that would come out I mean
if you stand by those policies if you're
a sanctuary City why wouldn't you
welcome these people in and provide for
them but I think in Martha's Vineyard
they actually deported them with the
National Guard like how can you say you
pro-sanctuary city but if you do as soon
as we see some people because I know
these border cities in Texas I think
they're overwhelmed so if you're if
you're a sanctuary City and you stand by
those policies why wouldn't you welcome
these people in your communities your
neighborhoods and help them dislike the
red states are doing or like Florida's
doing I mean one state can't take but so
many uh immigrants into the country
before they you know become overwhelmed
did you hear one they said
Martha's Vineyard isn't prepared like
the southern border of Texas is for
these number of migrants and they're
like what are you talking about it's
like 50. you got 50. they got 2 million
Obama's got plenty of room yeah and then
once you open your place to let them
live you know stay a little bit like
yeah I don't know about that we're not
going to respond to that one you know so
if you like this clip
Clips the entire podcast click right
here
thank you